（しゅっっ！）
（やらせじゃないよー！）
コホン...
こんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです。
急に「ピンポ～ン」って来て、とったら..
「トイレ貸してください...。」（意味不明）
って言われて..。
トイレっておいおい、お前ぇ!
オレん家入りたいだけだろー？
完全に怪しい。
完全に怪しいということで、一応
追い払ったんですけども...。
トイレ近くにどこありますかって言われて
ひとまず僕ん家の近くにコンビニがあるんで
そこのコンビニに
トイレがあるのでそっちに行ってくださいって言ったんですけど...。
（ちょっと気になるんで）
怪しいので、
ちょっと
問い詰めてみようと思います、今日は。
普通、人ん家のトイレ借りますかって言いますか？
絶対言わねーよ。
絶対言わねぇー。
いるかなぁー？
ちょっと見てみよう、外
(家の外確認中...)
（うーん）
（逃げたかな？）
い　な　い
いやいないけど怪しいなぁー。
絶対俺ん家行きたいんだな。
ちょっと待って怪しい...。
コンビニに行かせたんですけど
ちょっと...
問いただしたい。
なぜ俺のトイレ使おうと思ったかっていうのをちょっと聞いてみたいんで。
僕もコンビニに行きます！
ついでに昼ご飯です。
（足音）カタッ！カタッ！カタッ！カタッ！
（風）ごおおおおおおおおw
ピンポーンwww
『ありがとうございまーす。』
『一緒に写真撮ってもいいですか？』
ああ！いいですよ！いいですよ！
『ああ、すみません...』
あぁ、いいです！
『申し訳ないです。』
（写真撮り中）
『ありがとございまーす』
お仕事頑張ってください
『いえいえ！ありがとうございまーす！』
あざっす
（足音）カタカタ
（あっ！いたっ！）
うわー、絶対やばい。
やばい。やばい。バレた。早く。
バレた。バレた。バレた。
バレたバレたバレた。
完全にいた。
今完全にいた。
完全に今、俺…
いたよ。くそー、ハロウィンだからって
マリオのコスプレしてやがったよ。
俺完全に
捉えた。ここから見えるぞたぶん。
（ベランダから普通に見える犯人・・・）
（壁が見えているww）
よーし！ほら撮ったぞ。
撮ったぞ今！見た？！
完全に。完全にあいつらです。
話つけてきます。
え、どうしよう。
俺これ言ったほうがいいのかな。
難しいなー。完全に僕ん家
来ようとしてたんですよね。
いやー、逆に今撮ったから
逃げたかもしんないなー。
ビデオカメラに気づいたと思われる犯人。逃げたかも。
いなくなったなー。
たぶんいなくなった。
カメラを向けられたら
やっぱ怖いんですよね、人って。
僕も盗撮されるの怖いのと一緒で
カメラ向けられると怖いんでたぶん逃げたんだと思います。
これでもう来ないといいんですけど。
30分後・・・
えーと、今
twitterをちょっと
見てたんですけど、
完全にそれっぽいツイートがありました。
さっき見てたのそうですか？？
（おい！）
そうだよー！！！！
そうだよ！！
ｗｗｗじゃないよもうー…
完全になめてる・・・！
完全に俺んちに
いたじゃん。今の。
というわけでちょっとDM(ダイレクトメッセージ)を送って
僕んちにもう一回戻ってくるように言います。
来る奴はどんな気持ちで俺んちに来ているのか
ちょっとちゃんと僕もねやっぱ
言う時は言おうと思ったんでちょっと今日は
説教します。ガチです。
今日は。返事来るの待ちます。
（返事くるかな？）ぼーっとしてたら・・・
突然のピンポン！？
はい。
『あー、すいません。』
『さっきはあの、トイレの場所
教えてもらってありがとうございました。』
あ、いえいえ
『あのー、１つ聞いていいですか？』
はい。
『あのー』
（無言）
『YouTubeの方ですよね？』
（はじめ、考える）
ん、、まあ、
んー、そうですね。
あ、あの、どなたですか？
『僕もYouTubeやってまして』
『でー、まあいろいろ、あの昔から見てたんですよ。』
『あのTTの頃から』
『あのー、友達からー教えてもらってー
なんですけどもー、本当。』
『それはもう本当迷惑なのはわかってます。
すみません。』
『それは謝ります。』
ならくんなしｗｗ！！！！！
かああああん！！ｗｗ
『１回握手だけ〜してもらいたいな〜
って形なんですけども〜』
『もうそれだけしてくれたらニ度と来ないし』
『あの、ここのこと言わないし』
『はい』
『あのちょっと一瞬だけ〜』
『ちょっといいですかね』
わかりました。じゃあ今からちょっと
行きます。
説教
ターイム！！！！！！
あの、やらせじゃないからね。
（ドア）ガチャっ！
（えーと、なんて言おう）
あ、こんにちは。
どなたですか？
『あ、ぼく、の、あのー、そうですね』
『おぉすっげ〜』
（おぉすげ〜じゃねえ！）
『YouTubeやってまして、で』
さっきツイッター送った？
『送ってないです。』
あれ？送ってない？？
『送ったよ、送った送った』
『送ってないよ。』
『送ったよ。』『俺じゃないです。』
えーうそっ！
『送った、送った。』
え？おくったしょ？
『すみません。』
（は）え？だれだれ？誰に伝えてんの？
『ほんと申し訳ないです』
（は）あ、土下座しなくていいよww
誰から聞いたの？
『中学生3人・・・』
中学生かあ。
なるほどねぇ。あの、ホント・・・
家に来られると結構・・・今も編集しててさー・・・
『ですよね。←』
そう。
こういうのが続いちゃうとほんとに迷惑してて…
『もう二度としません』
フッフフッ、なにニヤニヤしやがって
静岡の人なの？
『静岡です』
最初のトイレ、トイレも貴様らか？（きょどｒ…
『え？』
ト、トイレ貸してくださいっていうのも
『そうですそうです』
おまえら…（怒）
動画撮ってるけど出してもいい？
たぶん顔とか全く映らないから。
『逆に移りたいです！』
でもたぶん移ったらたたかれるから
やめといた方がいいよ
街とかでさあ、会って・・・
話しかけられたりするのはいいんだけどさ…
家はプライベートの話だから…うん。
ホントに・・・家に来るのだけはやめてほしい
はいっ！わかりましたっ！
シャツってどこに売ってるんですか？
これは・・・もうすぐ販売されるビデのヴィレバンで・・・
ああ！ビデバンで！（は）そうｗｗビデバンでｗｗ
（は）よかったら買ってねｗｗ
（犯）いくらですか？
えー何円だろ？多分ここに
テロップで出てると思うんで
次から来たら通報することになるから
『はい！』
なるべく・・なるべくじゃない！
ヤメーロ、やめなさい
最後ちょっとボイパしてください。ボイパ！
（犯）ぷっつーくーつくつくつくぷー（ボイパ音）
（は）ぶっとぅーくーとぅくとぅく（ボイパもどき）
（犯）ははははははっ！
（は）馬鹿にしてんじゃねえ！
ひとまずもうくんじゃねえぞ
（犯）はいっわかりました。
その頭ってどうやってやったんですか？
おまえなああ、
おまえ悪いことしてる自覚あんのか！？
『ちょっ、サインもらっていい？』
サインはだめだ
もうくんじゃねえぞ
『はい、すいませんでした。ありがとうございます。』
一応注意はしたんですけどー
あんまり懲りてなさそうだったな…
あの、ほんとに、たぶん、
次から来たら全部通報します
即、警察呼びますんで。
えー、家には来ないでください。
はい。
というわけでマジメTシャツとシャチョーTシャツと
それのパーカーが、えーと
ヴィレッジヴァンガード、そして、
UUUMで販売されております。
あの、デザインがですね。
昔、僕ディスティニーって書いてある
Tシャツ着てたときあったと思うんですけども
あれをデザインしてくださった
はじめファンタジーさんという方に
作っていただきました
よかったらぜひ着てみてください。
普通にあったかいからね！
まったく今日の動画関係ないけどねｗ
ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓
みてくれてありがとー！
てーてれれれーれ
てれれれー
てれれれーれ
てれれ
てーてーれれ
てれれれーれー
ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓
ぺ・ぺ・ぺ・ペン☆
その日の夜
ぐわあああああああ
はい？すいません、もう一度いいですか？
『はじめしゃちょーですか？』ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
こどもかなあ？
かちゃっ！
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ